the rush to get out of afghanistan as
u.s and nato troops quickly end their
mission
it is clear to everyone that practically
everyone who can
is trying to leave the country at the
moment there appear to be three groups
of afghans the vast majority of the
people who
have no choice but to stay put and await
the future
the second group the only one whose
number is really swelling are those
fleeing the country iranian news media
report
thousands upon thousands of afghans are
crossing the border
every day and then there is the smallest
group
the translators and interpreters who
worked side by side
with allied troops some only for a few
months some for many years
there are thousands of them and they
want to get out
most applying for visas to the united
states the select ones
who have received the green light are
being flown out of the country
as we speak we have this report
we meet ahmad somewhere near new york
city
a former contractor and interpreter of
the u.s army
he found safety in america fearing
reprisals ahmad does not want to be
identified
his brother who is still in afghanistan
is facing
an uncertain future those individuals
are now in a lot of risks
there they work for the military
now if if they are left behind
the taliban will kill them it's a stress
to to check and see if your
loved ones are alive or they are dead
you when you
when the phone rings and no one answers
it's
it's a big pain
america's longest war began in 2001 when
it invaded afghanistan
following the attacks of 9 11. as the
troops now leave
18 000 former contractors are being left
without protection from the taliban
the u.s promised them special immigrant
visas and to relocate them
while their applications are being
processed but time
is running out it doesn't makes me happy
to see that
we like i spent 11 years of
hard work for the us army
and then i had to wait for four years to
get my visa
i bought to the youth government that
just
fulfill your promise and don't
let the people die volunteer jeff swartz
helped ahmad and other afghan families
settle in the united states
he says the u.s has a moral obligation
to protect those
who helped its troops this is a country
that has landed a rover on mars
and we're sitting here telling that
there's a process that has to be
followed
and we can't get 18 000 human beings
that whose lives are at risk
ahmad is lucky he applied for his visa
early
at the current rate his brother might
get his approved within three years
long after the u.s army has left
afghanistan
and for more i'm joined tonight by adam
weinstein he's a research fellow at the
quincy institute for responsible
statecraft he's an
expert on afghanistan where he also
served as a u.s
marine he joins me tonight from
washington d.c
and imran faraz he is an austrian afghan
journalist and
author he joins me tonight from
stuttgart here in germany to both of you
gentlemen it's good to have you
on the program imran let me start with
you is there a future for people
like those interpreters in afghanistan
first of all thanks for having me um i
think it's really difficult to say if
they have a positive future there
i mean it's not just about interpreters
who are still stuck in afghanistan
but also many other people you know the
nato personnel
that was built and recruited during the
last 20 years
all over the country is rather big and
many of them
are stuck because of you know
bureaucratic
uh issues that are not really reasonable
if you know the realities on the ground
i have just been busy with a case of an
afghan who used to work with the german
bundeswehr
he was not an interpreter but he was
responsible for the whole
telecommunication
of the troops and he regularly worked
with the troops every day for years
but now they are not interested in him
because he did not have
direct contract with the troops he
worked for a private firm and the
private firm
was working for the troops but you know
on the ground
for the taliban and other militants to
hunt down such people
this doesn't make a real difference so
does he is he he has to stay in
afghanistan then
yes exactly the german foreign ministry
literally said that they are not
interested in his case because
he did not have a direct contract so he
should take
care of him himself privately it's not
their business
okay adam let me come to you the united
states has pledged to evacuate these
translators
interpreters with their families and
that is taking place at the same time
it looks it looks a little bit like it's
an afterthought
is it uh well thanks for having me um
and uh i i'd have to say it is a bit of
an afterthought because
uh there was a lot of back and forth
over the withdrawal decision itself
and the cost of that indecisiveness
across both the trump and biden
administrations frankly
um and especially in the last few months
what was that there wasn't enough
planning
about the these contingencies like the
sib applicants and it might even be the
case that the
the pentacon uh was was dragging its
feet a bit
about a decision a withdrawal decision
that it didn't want to make
um that being said uh all
bureaucratic processes are tedious and
complex and i think what's necessary
here is for the biden administration
to cut through the red tape not allow a
bureaucracy to be used as an
excuse for allowing those who directly
supported us to be killed
and and simply get these people out it's
a task that is within the control of the
united states
most conditions in afghanistan are not
in the control of the united states
but getting the sib applicants out those
people who helped us directly
is something that is very much in our
control and it should be done
uh with uh speed and dispatch yeah and
we know that that is happening now they
they're being brought
to virginia while their visa
applications are being
processed and ron um for afghans
does your opinion of the u.s withdrawal
does it depend on
who you are and where you are
yes in my experience it does i think
what we often hear
in many western media reports is that
people are concerned
and of course many people are concerned
about what is happening
but what i experienced on the ground
is that it it's you know it's often very
different
and opinions differ from each other it's
often very heterogenic
also you have to consider that the life
of someone who lives in kabul in the
capital
is very different than the life of
someone who lives in rural afghanistan
like you know
in northern babylon province or in
northeastern
cornell province and you hear a lot of
different opinions about the withdrawal
and i think that uh
yeah that's that's what's going on over
there well um what do you hear dude do
people think that
a return of the taliban is in return of
the taliban to power do they think
that's now
inevitable
you know in kabul for example you hear
people who of course
fear such a return they think that a
scenario like in 1992
when the communist regime was toppled by
the mujahideen
would take place again and then you have
civil war and everything
in my opinion you already have civil war
in afghanistan if you consider what is
going on all over the country
but you know there are other regions
that have suffered from the american
occupation for example from airstrikes
drone strikes night raids
and if you talk to these people they're
rather happy that the americans leave
that's what was my experience for
example during my last reporting trip in
some of
the areas that i visited and
i think that a lot of afghans also know
that uh
you know foreign occupiers foreign
military forces
are not a constant solution to
solve the conflict uh in their country
yeah well they've had plenty of
experience with foreign occupiers that
is for sure
adam how do you see this is it is it
inevitable that the taliban returned to
power
or is that a message that the taliban
is trying to push
well i think it's a bit of both and look
you introduced me as an expert on
afghanistan and that's very flattering
i don't really consider myself one and i
think there's very few
uh genuine afghanistan experts in the
world and the reason i say that is
predictions about the political
trajectory of afghanistan
from anyone should always come with a
grain of salt
because they often times are wrong i
think that the taliban are
in an ascendant posture right now and
they've certainly taken a lot of
districts
we do have to remember that the and dsf
often retakes strategic districts
the taliban don't have enough manpower
to hold all of these districts
permanently
many of these outposts that the and dsf
had shouldn't really have existed
to begin with they were simply points on
a map that could
you know be pointed to and create the
illusion of government control over an
area
but in reality that outpost was on a
road that was controlled by the taliban
and couldn't be resupplied
and the reason the afghan soldiers
surrendered might have been to
lack of supplies or lack of ammunition
and and so i think the a and dsf
or the afghan security forces are going
to have to
reimagine the way they fight without
us air support and without the
logistical support
of the u.s military machine and they're
going to have to become more mobile and
coalesce around
population centers and of course these
are recommendations that u.s advisors
have
told the ghani administration uh for
some time now and told the afghan
government in general for it for years
um but there was a lack of political
will uh to
institute these reforms because uh there
it was bad optics or it might look like
uh the afghan government was giving up
territory
uh but now um there's not time
to consider optics the afghan government
has to focus um
on on uh keeping territory and regaining
strategic territory
and ultimately the only real solution
uh to what could be described as a civil
war with very powerful
third-party intermediaries uh or
intervenors
such as pakistan in the united states is
a political settlement
between afghans and at some point the
government and the taliban are going to
have to
meet each other halfway or else uh what
i think we're going to see is um
an ever intensifying uh civil war but i
do not think a taliban dominated
afghanistan
is inevitable at this moment okay i mean
well that's the future let's talk a
little bit
about the past adam you you served as a
marine in afghanistan and
you've said that you thought your task
was nation building
i want you to take a listen to what u.s
president biden what he said recently
about the mission in afghanistan
we did not go to afghanistan to
nation-build
and it's the right and the
responsibility of afghan people alone
to decide their future and how they want
to run their country
so adam the question is did the uf stay
too long
in afghanistan or should it never have
been there in the first place
well i think the united states was in a
position where it had to respond to 911
but that response could have been far
more limited and focused on
counterterrorism
than what it uh became and president
biden is correct when he says that the
original intent
and the original authorization uh by
congress for that matter
uh was not to engage in nation-building
activities
but there was a mission creep and uh
the mission creep and became
larger and larger to justify a longer
u.s presence to the american people and
and to the world
imran do you agree mission creep
yeah i think adam hinted towards some
really important points
regarding the political will of the
afghan national forces who are fighting
on the ground
i think that it's not just about
political will it's about the fact that
the afghan military is a deeply corrupt
kind of
institution that has a lot of problems i
mean
what adam described partly uh
you know you could you could go a bit
deeper and describe for example
the so-called ghost soldiers that
existed all over the country
you know soldiers who just existed on
the paper while
high-ranking military officials
literally stole the salaries of these
people
to make themselves rich and i visited in
march i visited
uh you know a couple of afghan soldiers
fighting
against the taliban in cornell province
and if you see these people you see what
the problem is they don't they literally
don't have
anything and are just on themselves
and uh i think regarding the nation
building issue
uh it's not just about what joe biden
said recently
uh from the very beginning the whole
intervention
was a failure because this the amount
they met the americans and their allies
started to work with very questionable
people on the ground in afghanistan
uh you know warlords drag barons
dracquarones and deeply corrupt
politicians
who all of them you know served in the
government of hamid karzai
and others are still still having high
ranking positions
and with such people it was very very
difficult from the very beginning
to get proper results well i've got
about a minute
left so let me ask boys of you gentlemen
i'll start with you imran and then i'll
hear from you adam what's going to be
the legacy of
the us presence in afghanistan imran you
first
i think the legacy of the us presence is
that
not the single goal of the us
intervention
was actually reached uh high-ranking
terrorists you know militant leaders
like osama bin laden
muhammad of the taliban all of them
were not hit by the so-called precise
operations of the americans
some of them even died naturally instead
many other people were killed
and dozens of people you know
thousands of thousands of people uh on
the ground
were radicalized joined the taliban
instead of
you know solving the terror problem in
afghanistan
we just see that much more terrorism has
been created
adam what about you the legacy is going
to be that the united states
should think twice about engaging in
interventions abroad because
afghanistan has demonstrated that the
the us military cannot
uh shape conditions on the ground but
perhaps the more important legacy is
what is the legacy going to be for
afghans uh and and ultimately are the
taliban and the afghan government going
to be able to
meet each other halfway and come up with
a political settlement
and the united states might be able to
revise its its legacy if it remains
engaged economically and diplomatically
even after u.s boots
leave the ground in afghanistan in fact
this is going to be a real test
for whether the united states actually
values diplomacy
uh when it is decoupled from military
intervention abroad
adam weinstein a research fellow at the
quincy institute for responsible
statecraft
and a former u.s marine and imran ferraz
an austrian afghan journalist
and author to both of you gentlemen we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you
you